sûrement l'on est devenu à des liens
je reviens de madame monsieur bonsoir à
bordeaux ce soir après cinq mois de
procès le réquisitoire du procureur
général est tombé ils demandent 20 ans
20 ans de réclusion contre maurice papon
pour complicité de crime contre
l'humanité pour terminer ce réquisitoire
a tout de suite provoqué une série une
réaction on se prive à eric attend les
mots du procureur général résonne encore
dans le palais lorsque les parties
civiles quitte la salle d'audience vingt
ans pour moi c'est la perpétuité réelle
le principal c'est une commence à perdre
la prison j'ai vibré à la fin au
réquisitoire du ministère public si l'on
présente étape mais vous aussi parce que
il l'a fait dans un souci de vérité et
de sincérité
aujourd'hui on a banalisé le crime
contre l'humanité demain il ne sera plus
possible à la procureure généralement
montcourt bassiste de requérir la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité si
aujourd'hui on ne requiert pas à faire
un tel défi victoire implacable contre
quelqu'un qui est convaincu de
complicité de crimes contre l'humanité
on m'a par un réquisitoire d'une telle
fermeté avec une démonstration aussi
implacable se termine par une réflexion
qui ne soit pas à la hauteur de
l'émotion
et et qui se développe et construit
moment prétoire je n'ai pas vu encore
quelqu'un de condamné contre l'humanité
pour lequel on demande des ltte
quelques minutes plus tard jean marc
barr où l'avocat maurice papon vient
spontanément devant les caméras on
propose qu'ils sortent à l'âge de 107
ans c'est en réalité une condamnation à
mort qui est demandé c'est à dire à
mourir en prison
discrètement maurice papon petit la
salle d'audience l'accusé
exténué semble très latin en allemand
par un réquisitoire qui a duré un peu
plus de huit heures mais y verrait un
bon soir 20 ans de réclusion comment
doit-on apprécié cette réquisition
oui d'autant plus qu'il ya ce soir un
sentiment d'avoir un réquisitoire de
l'incohérence 14 heures de
démonstrations en deux jours
une sorte de rouleau compresseur une
lourde charge pour arriver à la
démonstration donc la complicité
d'arrestation de séquestration et de
déportation de maurice papon nourrissent
pas qu'on se savait les mains sales
sales de la déportation des juifs bien
reed expo crocker général maurice papon
est le complice du crime le plus grave
concerne les enfants et des vieillards
et puis dans les cinq dernières minutes
eh bien le ton change vous devez être
impitoyable mais dans l'équipe et
maurice papon est aujourd'hui le seul à
répondre de ses actes nous ne voulons
pas d'un bouc émissaire
henri d'explo retire 20 ans dans un
silence pesant dans un silence incrédule
à leur choix qui pour retenir ce soir
deux choses ce réquisitoire d'avoir ses
20 ans requis le sont par un
représentant de la société mais aussi
par un représentant de l'état ce qui a
valeur de symbole dans un procès que
l'on est l'historique
enfin 20 ans requis 7 aujourd'hui la
création d'une nouvelle notion qui fait
de maurice papon un petit criminel de
l'humanité merci dominique à la veille
de l'élection des présidents de conseils
régionaux et du second tour des
cantonales les offres de services du
front national à la droite pour
conserver sa majorité de leurs
employeurs régions et départements
tourner au séisme politique quelle que
soit en effet les consignes les plus
fermes et les exclusions en cas
d'alliance avec
décidée par le rpr et l'udf certains
élus de droite reste tempétueux ont même
franchi le pas c'est à ce point qu'à la
mi journée et le premier ministre lionel
jospin a fait une déclaration solennelle
mais tant qu'on garde contre toute
alliance de la droite avec l'extrême
droite qui serait à terme at-il un
danger pour la démocratie
cette déclaration a aussitôt provoqué
une réponse cinglante du président du
rpr philippe ses glaces adressant lionel
jospin il a lancé les leçons qu'il se
les garde
retour sur une journée shirt moulant
déclarations et rebondissements
guilaine chenu je bâtis c'est déjà la
deuxième réunion de la journée les 10h30
et devant les cadres de son parti
philips et gab a réaffirmé la position
du rpr ni accord ni alliance avec le
front national
une ligne a imposé la bad est divisée
l'excommunication peut-être la désertion
que devront acquitter les droits donnés
par le secret des urnes
je suis pour la ligne les voir finir
sans ambiguïté à quelques rues plus loin
de la majorité plurielle qui réuni ses
chefs
il est 11 heures robert mutt françois
hollande et les autres viennent
d'annoncer la course inhabituelle à
gauche le désistement au deuxième tour
des cantonales au quart barrage au front
national
mais la situation est jugée suffisamment
grave pour que tous lors d'un appel
selon eux des accords entre la droite
une partie de jean marie le pen menace
la démocratie la république
ils ne le savent pas encore mais dès
maintenant tu es le nez chez soi qui
s'apprête à intervenir une déclaration
solennelle préparé depuis la veille le
premier ministre estime qu'il est de son
devoir d'intervenir en tant qu'une des
autorités de l'état il met en garde
contre du d'accord avec un parti qui ne
respectent pas les valeurs républicaines
est d'accord qu'il faut serait selon lui
le sens du vote des électeurs je ne fais
aucun procès d'intention aux dirigeants
de l'opposition
j'ai entendu des déclarations très
claires
je ne veux donc pas croire qu'il ne
veuille et qu'il ne puisse empêcher ces
alliances si elle devait toutefois se
produire demain ce serait un danger pour
notre vie démocratique
ce serait une atteinte à l'image de la
france
en france en europe et dans le monde
j'appelle chacun à la vigilance et à
l'exercice de sa responsabilité même
moment la réunion des cadres du rpr
s'achève officiellement pas de
contestation et pas question de laisser
lire des présidents de région avec les
voix d'extrême droite
mais philippe sega va surtout réagir à
l'intervention de lionel jospin dans le
débat que ceux qui ont pris leurs
responsabilités que nous de mettre en
péril effectivement les démocraties ne
facilite en jour après jour et à cette
heure même dans des déclaration sur le
perron de l'hôtel matignon
le cerf province edition le fonds
national que ceux qui portent cette
responsabilité
haïti ont gardé un ciblage nous
préférons nous préférons la situation
digne qu'est la nôtre nous nous devons
nous détacher en lien la personne en
revanche ne se pose pas en quoi sa
majorité à la décision des dirigeants du
front national alors un bon conseil si
vous pouvez lui transmettre les leçons
chevé garde au rp on revendique toujours
12 présidence de région
mais comme l udf l'état major doit faire
appliquer ses décisions sur le terrain
pour tenter de clore le débat qui vend
la droite
point d'orgue de la journée enfin à
l'occasion de l'inauguration du salon du
livre le président la république jacques
chirac s'est exprimé à son gré d'avoir
qui n'est pas très sage
d'utiliser ces questions a dépeint de
polémique politicienne ou partisane et
en plus ça peut être dangereux
quant à moi je tire d'abord de
l'élection y viennent d'avoir lieu le
sentiment que la protestation qui s'est
exprimé que l'abstention est forte
montrent qu'il nous faut aujourd'hui
nous occuper davantage des vrais
problèmes des français
enfin j'estime que lorsqu'on a des
convictions républicaines ce qui est mon
cas mais ce qui est le cas heureusement
d'une très grande majorité de français
et bien il ne faut pas transiger il faut
les respecter
il ne faut pas accepter de compromettre
autant alors qu'il est quel que soit
donc les prises de position ou plus haut
niveau on vient de le voir les consignes
données par les états majors parisiens
de la droite
les tentations la d'alliances et de
soutien avec le front national ne sont
pas rejeter en bloc sur le terrain dans
plusieurs régions et départements ont
négocié plus ou moins au grand jour
olivier car c'est la carte officielle
des élections régionales rouge quand la
gauche est en tête bleue quand c'est la
droite jaune en cas d'égalité mais le
rpr et l'udf c'est une autre carte qui
prend forme celle où les digues érigées
entre la droite et le front national
risquent de se fissurer en picardie en
languedoc-roussillon les chefs de file
de la droite semble bien décidé à
accepter les voix du fn pour garder la
présidence des conseils régionaux
d'autres régions mais en provence alpes
côte d'azur et en ile de france comme en
aquitaine ou en midi-pyrénées locaux ont
fait savoir au moins clairement que
l'union n'était pas possible avec le
front national
parmi les régions le problème d'une
alliance éventuelle avec le front
national se prolonge avec le plus
d'acuité la région provence alpes côte
d'azur avec notamment l'appel de
chimères de villes comme nice l'ancien
front national jacques peyrat estimant
qu'il serait anormal que la gauche
minoritaire dans la région s'empare de
l'appel du conseil national jacques
peyrat ne se contente pas de soutenir
ses candidats pour le deuxième tour des
cantonales
le maire de nice mais sion plein ciel
dans les régionales l'ancien membre du
front national aujourd'hui rpr attend de
la droite qu'il fasse barrage à la
gauche socialo communiste même avec les
voix du parti de jean marie le pen
et peu importe les consignes de philippe
rig je pense y ait un candidat de la
droite libérale est unique elle qui se
présente à l'élection vendredi
je souhaite me soigne lui soufflant la
chercher
toutes les charges légende élu
démocratiquement de lieux trois maires
cette même logique le maire de cannes
lui aussi signataire de cet appel vient
de préciser qu'il ne souhaitait pas de
compromission quant à la gauche elle
aussi sans surprise il droit qui se
dévoile sait très bien qu'à une grande
porosité entre la droite et l'extrême
droite ce département un à la une luttre
actions concrètes aux manifestations la
manifestation aussi que les élus de la
droite républicaine en tête dans les
alpes-maritimes dimanche soir de
maintenir un candidat compris même si
françois léotard sud et nous aurons de
toute façon un autre candidat pour
répondre à l'aspiration des électeurs de
droite qui ont voté pour nous et qui
veulent défendre nos couleurs madénian
avec le front national la position de
françois léotard est clair notre
candidat potentiel de la droite reste
chaud du conseil d'état major les
ambitions personnelles se télescopent
dans une côte d'azur tendu par la droite
plurielle
histoire de conserver le pouvoir autres
régions importantes en question où la
majorité au conseil régional se jouera
demain une ou deux voix près on n'a pas
pâti d'aiguillés aux tirs ici rocher je
pense qu'il faut d'abord faire ménage
chacun un combat donnait à 39 ans sont
des sans voix la personne
difficile pour les policiers de chars
millions d'un être les propos tenus par
lionel jospin a mises en garde du
premier ministre hérite et n'espère qui
problèmes ni avec le front national
c'est en fini de régler tout cela
d'ailleurs une réunion à huis clos a
lieu en ce moment en haine afin de
préparer le vote de demain et ribout en
ont conscience des milthon des élus
n'hésitent pas à prôner un set par un
hochement le front national en france
seniors 100 % français 100% de lecteurs
je pense que l'on ne peut pas bannir
comme ça que la population ainsi
officiellement charles millon l'a dit et
répété il n'y aura pas d'accord avec le
front national mais des propos ont été
tenus le parti de jean marie le pen lui
fait les yeux doux parle de contacter un
climat de malaise
nous refuserons toute manoeuvre toute
compromission avec le front national
j'attends le monsieur vidéo et que ses
colistiers qui apparemment ne prennent
pas la même position war la déclaration
de monsieur price se prononce clairement
charles millon peut compter sur 60 élus
tout comme jean jacques queyranne
l'égalité parfaite de 35 front national
et surtout deux aiguilles dépendantes
décideront du sort de la région demain
matin plus encore ce matin à bordeaux
alain juppé est sorti du silence qu'il
observe depuis son départ de l'hôtel
matignon pour dire qu'il appelait la
droite à faire front face au front
national le débat a même convoqué
aujourd'hui l'intervention de l'évêque
de nîmes
monseigneur genoud kenya qui estime
qu'une éventuelle alliance avec le front
national et le président sortant de la
région languedoc roussillon l'unef
jacques blanc pouvait s'apparenter à de
la prostitution
enfin dans un communiqué jean marie le
pen a jugé l'intervention du premier
ministre déshonorant pour lui et sinon
par ailleurs que son parti est victime
d'un véritable racisme politique entre
le front national je n'y prête à
accueillir tous ceux qui n'ont plus leur
place occupée par jean michel carpentier
je vivais en commençant on est en train
d'assister peut-être un véritable signe
oui on est peut-être à la veille d'un
tournant dans la vie politique de notre
pays
la chute bernagou avec l'alliance
possible d'une partie de la droite avec
le fondation
c'est vrai que cela s'était déjà produit
en 1986 avec les mêmes hommes d'ailleurs
monsieur blanc est mort huit depuis
douze ans le front national est monté à
15 % il a gagné les villes et il s'est
installé un peu partout alors 1992
jacques chirac avait l'ancien un carnet
de tout accord avec l'extrême droite
respectée depuis par toute la droite
même ça qui ne l'acceptaient pas à l'udf
comme aux experts car celui qui est
devenu président de la république
parlait ouvertement le racisme
d'antisémitisme et de xénophobie pour
être lequel front national et si ce
petit bout là qui est peut-être en train
de craquer aujourd'hui contre l'avis de
jacques chirac qui demandons bien
d'entendre de ne pas transiger ni
d'accepter compromission contre les
efforts incessants de philippe séguin
nicolas sarkozy est bien la droite
républicaine et peut-être à la veille de
connaître une défaite historique mieux
défaite idéologique 200 points de sérum
et ne taclent jamais car ce discours
qu'a tenu philippe saga marc pourquoi
ici même ressemble à un appel du 18 juin
contre l'obscurantisme et le fascisme
rampant
mais comme à l'époque kelly seulement 11
convoitent tous élus de droite prêt à
des libérales en dirigeant point
fauteuil et qui tombent dans le piège
tendu par bruno mégret et saine sans
compter qu'il ya là de quoi inciter les
électeurs de droite à voter directement
front national la prochaine fois bien
sûr ce matin le premier ministre lionel
jospin est intervenu de façon solennelle
pour rappeler les valeurs républicaines
sommet de l'état ramènerait les élus
tenté de s'allier demain lexon droite
d'intervention pour demander aux
français de bien réfléchir aux
conséquences d'un tel dérapage dans le
pays car à n'en pas douter la france
d'une partie de son avenir politique
mais ça va venir tout simplement merci
jean michel une dernière information qui
provient la confusion actuelle il n'y
aura pas d'élection du président de
région ile de france demain soude de
quorum et conseiller régional rpr udf
ayant décidé de ne pas siéger demain
vendredi
c'est une affaire bien pénible que les
jurés de la cour d'assises le doigt et
honte à juger en 1994 une jeune femme
avait enlevé un bébé dans une maternité
de 2,1 après avoir simulé une grossesse
pour sa défense l'accusé explique
qu'elle avait besoin d'aimer et d'être
aimé car elle avait le sentiment de
n'exister opex virginie ficher de munich
extrêmement nerveuse nadège pourrait
bien du mal à se contrôler
lorsqu'elle s'adresse à la cour sa voix
tremblotante ses mains à 42 ans cette
femme aux traits tirés doit aujourd'hui
répondre d'enlèvement et séquestration
de mineur de moins de 15 ans il y a
trois ans et demi elle avait enlevé le
petit gros on donne alors âgée de quatre
jours de crise bnr en dépression
véronique la mère du bébé nous toujours
pas surmonté le traumatisme
aujourd'hui elles demandent justice il
poursuit tant chez très commencé trois
gymnases dans les box des accusés
malgré vers les coups de nadège continue
lui de neil une éventuelle complicité
accusé de séquestration cet homme de 49
ans à fillon ne s'être rendu compte à
aucun moment où la grossesse de sa femme
était contré simuler une allégation qui
reste le président gasteau très fair
play
l'étude de personnalité de nadège froide
hier a révélé une femme rusée mythomane
pour la défense une femme d'abord on
manque d'enfants et surtout en manque
d'amour un sentiment de solitude
et tout à l'heure je fais la démission
au président il vieillit mais je compte
onction je n'avais plus personne et elle
avait donc besoin d'un bébé soit un bébé
à elle sur lui même nadal pourrait bien
raconte j'ai pris ça publiquement puis
gelé soudés dans mes bras il dormait
vraiment comme un débit les parents de
brandon a qu'une le choc
nadège bréviaire elle risque jusqu'à 30
ans de réclusion féminin le chauffeur du
camion fou dont les freins avaient lâché
faisant neuf morts dans les rues de la
principauté d'andorre des cinq appareils
a consisté à son domicile
la région de lyon quelques semaines
après sa condamnation à huit mois de
prison avec sursis
ceci ne serait pas en relation directe
avec l épilogue 17 h les policiers d'un
jour saisie de la dynamite et des
explosifs dans les appartements et
maisons ont été arrêtés au début du mois
plusieurs membres importants du groupe
terroriste algérien gia revanche la
police belge dément avoir trouvé sur
place des documents relatifs au stade de
football des différentes villes
françaises où auront lieu les matchs de
la prochaine coupe du gilbert bourdin le
goût de la secte du mandarom à salé à
castellane dans les alpes-maritimes
vient de mourir à l'âge de 74 ans il
avait fondé l'ordre des chevaliers du
loot lotus d'or ce secte comptait
plusieurs milliers de fidèles en france
et à l'étranger
mise en examen pour viols et agressions
sexuelles en 95 il avait été laissé en
liberté sous contrôle judiciaire par les
chercheurs
geder bourdin était malade
lâché par la plupart
il a créé pour viol ils avaient fait
leur mise en liberté en raison de son
âge et de son état qui hantent et vient
deux ans celui qui se nomme et le mépris
cosmo clamé plaire annoncé déjà qu'il
renonçait à la mission une opération
hallucinante de prosélytisme né au début
des années 70 condamne hors norme
les chevaliers du non-stop pendant plus
de 15 ans ils organisent des cérémonies
pour sauver des fidèles de ce qu'il
appelle le low cost nucléaire un
comportement sectaire
les théories fumeuses une soirée
délirante de clients qui le poussera à
construire d'immenses édifices sur un
flanc de colline
actional aujourd'hui cette ample ne sont
plus habitée que par une quinzaine la
dette bien isolé pour lutter contre les
démons qui croient qu'ils veulent
exterminer
mauvaise surprise pour la société
pétrolière total qui à l'occasion de la
coupe du monde avait décidé de faire un
cadeau à ses clients des ballons de
football
le problème c'est que ces ballons
étaient fabriqués au pakistan par des
enfants ce que total ignorait le
caméraman rendu sur place en étroite
liaison avec la confédération
internationale des syndicats libres qui
depuis de nombreuses années mais le
combat contre le travail des enfants
ici les enfants fabriquent des ballons
de football avec une dextérité précis
si longtemps les grandes marques
européennes ou américaines pour un
salaire de quelques francs par jour tout
au plus
nos lunettes arrières cours du village
sont les blonds estampillé france 98 le
caméraman déco avec officiel de la coupe
du monde est celui de la compagnie total
elle même ce qu'on pensait ces ballons
se sont fait fabriquer pour le compte de
la société néerlandaise
suite suite un autre pot à quelques
kilomètres de la défense d'entrée
impossible de savoir si c'est un lieu de
production ou de stockage ce qui est sûr
qui peut suivre
fabien acheter le droit d'utiliser le
logo officiel sur ces ballons
commercialisé partout en europe et c'est
donc naturellement vers lui que la
compagnie total s'est tourné au
printemps dernier pour passer commande
au talent qui plaident aujourd'hui de
bonne foi en présentant ce document
n'était du mois de mai dans lequel ce
mythe précise que les ballons sont
cousus main avec contrôle qu'aucun
enfant ne soit impliqué
on est consterné surpris arrêter
immédiatement toute relation commerciale
la société smyd at elle confie elle même
la fabrication infiltrés au pakistan
l'enquêté le dira en quelques jours
difficiles tous les fabricants y vous
signer une charte de bonne conduite
l'an dernier les contrôles sur place à
identifier car c'est chaque famille
chaque maison il faudrait contrôler
entre huit et dix mille membres des
professions paramédicales infirmières
kinésithérapeutes orthophonistes ont
défilé aujourd'hui à paris ils
s'estiment mal traités par la sécurité
sociale qui a décidé de récompenser les
efforts des sols médecins auraient lutte
contre les déficits des caisses maladie
leur permettant par ailleurs d'augmenter
leur
lequel il annonce un bénéfice net
aujourd'hui de 20 milliards de francs
pour 90 rentes fois plus qu'en 96 la
banque a amélioré sa rentabilité et
l'aide de l'état a permis en partie
également que son retrait
la sélection à la fédération nationale
des syndicats agricoles reçu aujourd'hui
par le président de la république pour
lui dire qu'elle n'était pas d'accord
avec la réforme de la politique agricole
commune qui remplace les agglos bad aux
agriculteurs par des aides directes à la
baisse
le président leur a répondu que dans
l'état actuel des choses et bien
bruxelles a des devoirs rangement sa
copine c'est également l'avis de lionel
jospin
ouverture à paris de la conférence
mondiale sur l'eau non devenu une
matière précieuse pour notre planète
continent sont inégaux face aux matières
premières
un européen par exemple consomme 200
librement par jour en afrique un cran
mais il n'ya pas que des problèmes de
pénurie le continent sud-américain qui
est le mieux synchronisée du monde
connaît lui aussi des problèmes de
réseau d'approvisionnement dans ces
grandes mégapoles comme buenos aires ma
chance j'ai présenté par la terre
minière du groupe suez lyonnaise des
eaux avec le plus gros contrat demande
assurer l'alimentation en eau de 10
millions prévus dans la pierre m
hier contient des ingénieurs des lots
formé par des centres et il roule vers
san isidro un bidonville de la
périphérie de buenos aires dans la
capitale argentine
on est riche ou cours contre des
responsables du chantier d'alimentation
en eau potable
le chef de ce quartier peu sûrs et un
calibre est là pour l'accueillir car
sans commettre pas question de
s'aventurer dans le dédale des ruelles
un million de personnes
il en arrivait peu plus chaque année
face à la misère il a fallu improviser
le raccordement est gratuit et pour que
nous les habitants de la prennent pas le
faire eux mêmes effets
j'exprime une personne de ce quartier je
vois tu avoir l'eau courante à la maison
une révolution dans la vie de tous les
jours ah c'est sûr ça va nous changer la
vie pour se laver pour les toilettes
jusqu'à présent à l'eau courante n'y a
pas de pression bien la machine à laver
mais elle ne peut pas lui même pas cher
de toute façon il faut avoir du travail
pour la nuit
douze fois par mois pas plus lionhead et
l'a promis il équipe à deux n'ont pas de
grève donc pas de facture sera le rôle
de gomme est de collecter l'argent il ne
fera bénévolement pour la bonne cause
ici il y a un problème sanitaire le plus
souvent des maladies d'estomac
d'ailleurs nous tous ici vous agglo des
rigoles qui coule dans les rues les
ghettos que voir les 10 millions
d'habitants de buenos aires la rendre
potable et accrétive la couche riches
des pauvres c'est le contrat que
l'entreprise française a passé avec
l'état argentat pas de problème de
pénurie
l'eau arrive aux portes de la ville
sinon rio de la plata l'opérer dans le
fleuve est traité dans cette usine
l'une des plus grandes du monde
aujourd'hui rénovée elle retrouve ses
performances conduisent chaque jour
trois millions de mètres cubes d'eau
potable rencontrés ici de l'état dans
lequel étaient les équipements pendant
20 ans ou 30 ans il n'y a pas eu
d'investissements de fait pour faire la
maintenance nécessaires d'installation
son arrivée en 1993 c'était française
par occuper l colmater les fuites
mais fera en coupure pause ou quelques
kilomètres de puyoô par jour aujourd'hui
ce courage à 30 mètres sous terre et le
gros morceau du contrat on l'appelle le
petit tunnel sous la manche de bellver
une galerie de 15 km2 qui n'est un
fleuve d'eau potable au bout un million
et demi d'abonnés
d'autres cette danse est mineur bolivien
se relève pour du tunnelier toute perte
est large et 30 m c'est très dur
dieu pourquoi à cause de l'humidité
journée dans l'eau toute la journée
reste maintenant le plus difficile à
faire accepter la facture
l'orignal les musées mais c'est non un
plan social a divisé par deux les
effectifs de l'ancienne tour s'était
déroulé à buno lierre l'achat sera payé
a commenté la lyonnaise des eaux est
tous très content
il s'agit pour elle de rentabilité 24
milliards de francs d'investissements
l'actualité internationale le ministre
des affaires étrangères français hubert
védrine également rendu visite
aujourd'hui au président serbe milosevic
après l'entretien la menace de l'embargo
a été repoussé les négociations avant
son effet sur un nouveau projet
d'autonomie de la province du kosovo à
majorité albanaise sur place pour autant
la tension reste vive dans les rues de
la principale du mot son
cristina arigho qui joue on négocie la
bbc la communauté internationale
dix jours pour que serbes et albanais
accepte au moins de ce soir à la même
table pour négocier la au dixième jour à
pikine à défilement
mais j'attends leur côté emile albanais
encore aujourd'hui pour réclamer une
autonomie du kosovo cet après-midi les
herbes protéger tout le contraire le
maintien de la province à majorité
albanaise au sein de la sorte c'était 40
milles du jamais vu depuis 10 mhz comme
s'il s'agissait pour chacun des deux
camps de compter ses partisans avant le
scrutin organisé par les alpes
dimanche alors évidemment les
affrontements à coups de pierres et de
bâtons au moment où les coups de cortège
qui sont croisés à terre un caméraman je
compte beaucoup
le seul blessé de la journée un miracle
aujourd'hui à pristina les forces
spéciales serbes n'ont pas tiré dans le
fond ce n'était pas le talent hier à
pécs où un manifestant albanais été tué
d'une balle par la police serbe ont
l'empiré cet après midi depuis fin
février
déjà 80 morts et des centaines de
blessés où sont les français et c'est de
s'ouvrir au monde en apprenant notamment
les langues étrangères mais les
gouvernements français successifs et
c'était canon de conserver à notre
langue
son rayonnement international à
l'occasion de la semaine de la
francophonie demain voici un point un
reportage réalisé à pékin capitale
chinoise le français est la troisième
langue étrangère là bas a enseigné dans
les écoles essentiellement pour le
business le commerce la belle des fleurs
universel de péter et spécialisée en
économie on y enseigne dix langues
étrangères le français arrive en
troisième position derrière l'anglais le
japonais
c'est une petite langue cette étudiante
en quatrième année option français
gestion la france finance ici de
lecteurs à plein temps et un professeur
visiteurs par mois en gestion maîtrise
en génie
choisi de venir deux ans en chine pour
le compte de la fondation française pour
l'enseignement de la gestion foncière
générale comme on a pu longtemps les
gens qui ont un autre raison des infinis
rencontrer quelqu'un et d'un coup c'est
qu'ils le pensaient les étudiants qui
font les cent pas dans le patio aux
samoa français alors être qui fait déjà
un niveau impressionnant lors de
l'examen oral chacun va tirer un sujet
qui leur à 10 minutes en héros pour
préparer cet accident
c'est le français position car même pour
les employeurs français en chine
notre langue et puis la priorité absolue
lors d'un recrutement
il demande chinoise les chinois ont donc
de moins en moins besoin d'apprendre
notre langue pour commercer avec nous
par ailleurs la présence chinoise en
afrique ce uniquement amenuisé ces
dernières années
l'enseignement du français recule de
temps une érosion difficilement
réversible mais quand s'arrêtera
finissent toujours par avoir raison tout
pour moi en matière musicale en effet
après le déferlement des casse tête puis
dcb la mode du disque vinyle revient et
ce sont les dj venus que je qu'elky son
coin de vinyle c'est excellent pour la
musique techno
reportage nicolas winckler film
un petit coup on n'y croyait plus trop
ce sont les musiques électroniques celle
du xxième qui veulent qu aujourd'hui au
cours de l'année semble de plus en plus
nombreux et durablement les industriels
eux-mêmes noronha regarde ça l'important
il ya deux ans fabriqué à peu près
puisque venus par jour et à l'heure
actuelle attendant trois équipes de
nombreux jeunes musiciens satisfait pas
et sans leur dire la peine mais il prend
les 500 exemplaires du production qui
inondent des boutiques spécialisées
une création libre hors des sentiers
battus seront pas nous aurait facilement
car physiquement a donc à partir de là
on peut tester les trucs des coûts est
plus fatigant vont dans ce sens au
ministre le préfet peut prendre c'est
des gens qui vous est l'un des grands
disques jeter de la scène techno deux à
trois fois par semaine il fait le tour
des boutiques spécialisées de la
capitale ce sont sept puisque jockey qui
fonde une première sélection parmi les
productions très tôt qu'on leur propose
le il déniche les talents de demain
c'est ainsi qu'a démarré sa carrière
dieu
sa voix ses clients sont pas aussi qu'un
peu d'écho ma réaction de la foule de
danse et de plus en plus importante de
les producteurs et il arrive souvent
qu'on se lance dans la production d'un
disque laser avec un minière comprend
maintenant pourquoi les vinyles et le
quotidien des disques je peux regarder
il permet des techniques
cd dis ce que je pense à la touche amman
les vinyles permet souplesse et création
et sur le conflit peut pas faire ça et
la deuxième raison pour laquelle on
utilise beaucoup de vinyle c'est parce
qu'il aime beaucoup de titres trompé par
des jeunes connecteurs et keith a
d'abord sur les plus tard peut-être
céder parfois jamais c'est avec le
support le plus rustique que s'exprimer
guy le mouvement musical le plus juteux
limite du passé faisons table rase et
basse pointe et insensiblement il s'est
installé dans le paysage du cinéma
français à 27 ans vincent elbaz avec ce
physique de mousquetaire devient la
coqueluche des réalisateurs après est la
vérité si je mens il a enchaîné les
randonneurs et aujourd'hui les petites
gens amoureux
vincent elbaz un jeune homme qui le
monde vit sans avoir l'air d'être semble
devoir se passer depuis deux ans
lui permettent aujourd'hui mais aussi
ses roues la pagaille de la semaine
l'espace pose des questions c'est ça moi
je suis dans ce métier même les
s'enflamme seulement quand ils nous
connaissent peut-être depuis lundi dans
lequel il interprète un adolescent a
perdu dans cette comédie de moeurs trick
quittons mai par le journal à
l'interdiction des pointeurs laser vous
savez ces petits pointeur laser qui
risque d'être très dense
la france vient d intervenir à l'avant
surtout lorsqu on les dirige vers les
yeux ces objets étaient déjà interdits
en grande bretagne par exemple voici lé
22 joueurs retenus pour le prochain
match de préparation de l'équipe de
france de football qui va jouer pour la
russie de retour lamouchi l'auxerrois et
karembeu qui s'est fini c'est en coupe
d'europe me reçoit avec le real madrid à
l'argent le bull français lama qui bien
qu'il joue actuellement en grande
bretagne n'a pas été sélectionné par
aimé jacquet arnaud quitté le rappel des
principaux titres
c'est beau pourquoi
je
je trouve